foreign
Journal reads the IRS wants to look at
your bank account on your next trip to
the ATM imagine that Uncle Sam's looking
over your shoulder as if your annual tax
filing wasn't invasive enough the Biden
Administration would like to look at
your checking account
Charles reddig the commissioner of the
Internal Revenue Service wants Banks to
report annual cash flows for ordinary
account holders treasury secretary Janet
Yellen is promoting the plan and the
house Ways and Means Committee is
debating whether to include this mandate
in the Democrats 3.5 trillion dollar
spending Bill Ms Yellen says the
reporting will help to catch wealthy tax
Dodgers in a recent letter to the
committee she said the plan would reveal
opaque income streams that
disproportionately accrue to the top
yeah the re the wealthier evil and I'm
sure they're all hiding their money in
the bank you stupid woman
seriously
well this is uh this is unbelievable had
had I not seen that this was an actual
article I would have thought this was a
spoof from the onion this is so
unbelievably outrageous that the federal
government is kicking around the idea of
being able to look into our bank
accounts let me tell you something this
is gonna get nasty right here because uh
there's there's always another way
around it every time government tries to
move and pivot to take away our personal
freedom uh people figure it out and I
hope some bankers are paying attention
right now because if I I I can you
imagine can you imagine that this would
not help deposits that's what I'm saying
yeah it's going to disrupt and destroy
an industry I gotta tell you the IRS
plans to review every account above a
600 balance
or because that's the people that are
these are the wealthy tax Dodgers here
well there's the catch that's not about
wealthy people it's about everybody yeah
it's about control again it's time for
some pitchforks to come out I gotta tell
you a little bit of a yeah probably a
couple of uh torches to go with the
Pitchfork yes it's also a privacy breach
waiting to happen not long ago the
confidential tax records of just Bezos
Mike Bloomberg and other wealthy
Americans were exposed by Pro publica uh
whoever leaked or hacked those records
committed a crime but the IRS has
revealed nothing from its promised
investigation adding bank account info
to the IRS Trove would dis risk the
disclosure of savings and spending
information of political adversaries in
the same way no that would never happen
23 State treasures and auditor signed a
letter last month opposing the plan
calling it one of the largest
infringements of data privacy in our
nation's history you think by the way
watch this watch how this might just
flood the cryptocurrency thing becoming
an outside Fringe thing to an act
everyday thing that's why this thing is
out there I'm not endorsing it at all I
don't do anything with it I want to be
very clear but that's where this is
coming from because of this government
overreach you watch it it's just gonna
if this happens or even tries to happen
it's going to create a tidal wave of of
mistrust and all kinds of problems it's
laughable it's so absurd it really is
it's it's it's mind-blowing that that
they think that this could actually
happen well they yeah and and you know I
would think that probably one of the
more powerful lobbying groups
even for Democrats would be the bankers
ABS that's why I laugh and I would think
that they would put their big heel on
this and grind
because this is going to create
um
a lot of cost for them because they have
to build systems to report this to
comply
this is like this is a billions and
billions of dollars of cost for the
banking industry yeah
my God if you got 750 Joe Biden wants to
know it oh yeah and first of all let me
just say this I I have no this is
opinion I just don't think this has any
legs to it all it's so ridiculous but
the emperor is officially not wearing
clothes that's where we are right now
this is such an unbelievable
yes on top of everything else he's
taking his clothes birthday suit needs
ironing yes yes it does don't do that
yeah it's just so absurd that this that
this policy would even be floating
but it's
you know it goes along with a lot of the
covet overreach and some of these other
things that are overreaching
constitutional rights
um and it's been going on for some time
yes and uh just how much
before people bow up on it
um I think this would do it apparently
there's a weather problem with Southwest
air right now weather the weather
everywhere Southwest air is flying is
bad yeah and so uh they're struggling
with weather and everywhere they land is
a problem yeah so yeah there's this is
gonna this has the these statements and
policies and supposed things even if you
don't Implement them if you just toss it
out there like a trout balloon with that
as a grenade attached to it uh it still
has implications that's a great point
you know it reverbs through these
industries that's absolutely a great
Point Dave this is a threat to privacy a
threat
right now it's a thread it's not an
attack yet but it's a threat and I don't
know if there's anything more private
than our bank accounts you start talking
about people's money
I mean we're talking you've been doing
this for a long time we're talking crazy
emotions around oh your money and the
privacy of that yeah this is a threat to
privacy that's what this is you know
it's like a a Banana Republic where you
can't trust the banking system so you
have to keep your money under a mattress
and you have to stay off the grid
because you can't it's not trustworthy
it's correct why they steal the cheat
and you know some of these crazy
countries and if we're are we going to
devolve into that with this kind of
movement out of the federal government
of course the good news is we've got a
group of Governors
on several of these issues that are
saying uh your overreach doesn't extend
across our state line we're not going to
allow it and then we've got another
group of Governors that went oh yeah
we're all in uh whatever you want to do
we're with you Big Joe yeah this is out
of control out of control the Tyranny is
uh is real
so yeah just let them poke around in
everybody's bank account not to mention
how much that costs not to mention how
much you do but every time you get ready
to move your money that you earned they
want to know about it
uh yeah we'll see how that works out
this is the Ramsay show